hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from yesterday's cake defy
christmas arena uh that was played
unleashes in bullets time format uh
unfortunately we did not get to finish
the event we only uh got to around 50
minutes of the event and then the
servers crashed and we had to well
postponed the tournament uh there's
nothing uh well that we could have done
as uh they had to do some uh
you know diagnostics and they said it
will take at least two days to
see what actually happened and to
prevent such a thing happening in the
future uh probably it had something to
do with uh the there being 19 000 people
in the tournament but uh you know could
we could be anything else so we'll see
what they say and depending on what they
find in their uh well troubleshooting we
will decide what to do with the
tournament it's definitely postponed
until january because now we don't have
uh simply the time to
uh to set it up as we have the world
rapid and blitz championship coming up
um from december 25th to december 30th
and we're gonna well we're just gonna
have to postpone it
uh until january and uh the depending on
what they find will uh either continue
the tournament uh in the exact same
moment where it finished uh you know in
the exact same time with the exact same
points for everyone and we'll try to
coordinate it with most of the players
to see if uh at least those in the top
maybe 20 can can can join the tournament
as uh well of course we can't coordinate
with everyone that was in uh but we'll
try to
make it happen like that or if uh there
is evidence that the tournament wasn't
functioning properly uh for the first 15
minute minutes of its duration then
we're gonna have to restart the
tournament and start it from scratch so
there are some other options of course
but uh those are those are the main two
that we are uh considering so we'll see
what happens it all depends uh what they
find so this is one of the games i
wanted to show you guys as hikaru was
leading the tournament when uh
uh when the service crashed he's playing
against daniel dubo of uh mevco on only
chess and it's uh it's a really
enjoyable game very very precise game
for a bullet so i hope you guys enjoyed
and a lot of you guys were saying in the
uh in the live chat that uh okay maybe i
should just have made it the titled
arena maybe you know not not allow
everyone to join uh but that kind of
goes against of what i was trying to do
i was trying to you know it's a
christmas arena i was trying to give
everyone an opportunity to play against
some of the
some of the big names even if just for
the first few minutes of the tournament
because if you lose games and they win
games of course they will be paired with
the winners uh but even that i thought
it was a very nice opportunity for you
guys to maybe face i don't know nakamura
or dubois here or even magnus or alireza
but
i don't know if it will be possible if
they say it's okay and well this was now
definitely a fine stress test uh so
maybe we'll conduct it in in the same
way uh but if not we're gonna have to uh
limit it with uh some sort of an
additional criteria uh maybe rating wise
maybe the other well we will get into
that depending on what they find and
then we're going to discuss it so this
is just a small update uh that being
said uh let's check out the game uh this
is the i think the last game hikaru
played before the server crashed or
maybe he had another one in but i don't
know if that one
was finished due to
the server issue so let's just check it
out hikaru has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 double replies with c5 he
goes for the sicilian defense and hikaru
goes knight to c3 opting for the close
sicilian we have knight to c6 and now f4
going for the grand prix attack uh e6 by
do both and now knight to f3 and do both
strikes in the center with the d5 and
the bishop to b5 so this is all very
standard stuff of the grand prix and of
course both of them know this and here
usually black will go knight to e7 or
knight to f6 i think knight to e7 is
considered the main move but here dubo
plays a very very
rare move and that is bishop to d7 uh
it's not okay that rare but it is giving
up a pawn and i think only one person
played it uh uh
up until this point uh but he wants to
get some rapid development in and okay
hikaru happily accepts the pawn with e
capture c captures and knight captures
on d5 duo develops the bishop we have
bishop to d6 and hikaru just castles uh
we have knight g to e7 attacking the
knight on d5 hikaru trades and do both
captures back with the bishop there is
one game in the database where knight
captures was played but here we have
bishop captures on e7 and it's now as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game so hikaru wants to open up things
as dubois king is still in the center of
the board and he starts with d4 we have
c captures on d4 but now hikaru doesn't
capture back uh he just goes uh rook to
e1 the king is still on e8 so he wants
to get some development in we have
castles by dubois and now a3 by taking
away the b4 square from from black's
pieces also preparing this pawn uh to be
pushed to b4 bishop to f6 and now bishop
back to d3
so a pretty equal position now hikaru
gave back the pawn uh and uh well let's
see what happens we have rook to c8 to
do both continuous development and the
bishop to d2 now this is how hikar will
develop the bishop rook to e8 and now uh
only now b4 so bishop to e6 uh and now
comes queen to e2 not afraid of this
rook on e8 because there simply aren't
any good discoveries for the bishop so
bishop d5 is played but hikaru just
moves it queen to f2 putting some
pressure on f on d4 but you are of
course not uh
hoping to capture that just yet uh and
here uh we have rook captures on e1 an
interesting idea for do both here is
rook to e3
but
it's one that you would have to
prepare and for a bullet game uh of
course that's not uh
uh
you know it's easier said than done even
though this is a two plus o bullet i'm
not sure if they berserked this game uh
so you do have a little bit of an
additional time to to think uh of course
the rook could not be captured because
if you capture then this pawn is a
monster and if you recapture them bishop
d4 will will just be very scary for
example rook captures an e3 also bishop
captures an a1 so there's uh yeah there
are many many tricks in the position so
rook captures any one was played we have
rook capture sunny one and now a6 by do
both and now knight to g5 so both
players still have the bishop fare uh
and of course hikaru is hoping that he
can win the bishop pair uh
will eliminate to one of dubo's bishops
so here h6 kicking back the knight
knight to e4 now attacking the f6 bishop
and here dubo could capture on e4 and
it's a perfectly fine move but he wants
to keep the bishops in the game he plays
bishop to h4 and now knight back to g3
by hikaru uh we have queen to f6 and now
comes queen to e2 here this is a
i would say a classic uh hikaru position
as he plays uh a lot of puzzle rush and
if you if you had this position and you
had to solve it in a puzzle rush i think
he would play queen to e2 instantly uh
as it sets up a trap for duboff and you
have to
see it uh otherwise you're just dead
lost but dubois missed it uh duval
played the g6 of course you want to make
this bishop a little bit less powerful
but the this comes with a big problem so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for hikaru while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
well the rook is undefended and also uh
well the other thing uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course queen to g4 now what's the
idea here well of course you are
attacking the rook and c8 but more
importantly you are aligning the queen
with the king and that prepares knight
to h5 and that's the whole point we want
to take away the queen well this
diagonal from the queen and the queen
will not be able to defend the bishop uh
so what can you play here well duboff
played rook to d8 uh but this is uh well
just terrible as now comes knight to h5
and he was in this position on move 24
that daniel dubo resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
the queen is attacked once you move the
queen the bishop will fall yes you can
capture back the knight but black's
position will be completely shattered
but just to give you an idea of how
hopeless black's position is let's say
queen d6 we're going to play queen
captures on h4 g captures on h5 you win
back your piece but now f5 and black has
no moves it's uh such a bad position for
black that it's uh
it's it's hard to imagine that it can
even arise from such a position but you
can see how quickly hikaru spotted it he
prepared with queen e2
and then just uh you know completely
shattered the position with queen to g4
the problem now is uh you can't uh put a
rook on the e file so you really don't
have any moves with the rook you can't
play knight e7 that's covered by the
rook uh if you play knight to the e5 we
can just capture it because then the
queen no longer guards the rook so
obviously that's not working so what can
you play the bishop has no useful moves
you know
you can just play some silly moves like
f6 we're going to capture on h6 then on
h5 and the position completely falls
apart so i imagine double was uh you
know he spent a few seconds looking at
the position he was disgusted by it uh
you know completely and utterly and then
he resigned the game
uh so yeah very nice very nice victory
for hikaru i hope you guys uh enjoyed
this game and that you guys enjoyed
watching the
uh the live coverage on any channel as
i see a whole lot of people were uh
streaming it and some of them were
covering only carlson's games i think
jerry from chess network only followed
magnus some of them followed the players
they like i i decided to
follow someone uh from the top 10 uh
well depending on what the position on
the board was and and maybe if it was
the beginning of the game if it was uh
an interesting position but uh yeah it's
impossible to cover all of them and uh
you're just too spoiled for choice uh
but yeah this was a
very good experience and we will
definitely try to uh prevent such a
thing from happening in the next one
either by uh alicia sorting it out and
seeing what went wrong uh because it
shouldn't be a problem for them so i'm
sure something that shouldn't have
happened has happened or we will have to
limit the number of players by well any
any sort of criteria that will allow
them to to proceed with the tournament
uh so i will keep you guys informed uh
no worries there and well i hope you
guys enjoyed this uh as usual uh you
guys can check two of my previous videos
uh here i would like to thank the jube
mateo uh marchessini yeah andre lozario
eric mumford and timothy rosen for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it uh yeah i
already said you can check them out here
as usual uh and uh yeah i will see you
guys very soon checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh
we will see and yeah uh the tournament
continues in january
in a few days we're starting with the
world blitz and rapid championship thank
you all and i will see you soon have a
great day